[Music]
thank you
I can't believe you took a picture of me
while I was sleeping not a view of us I
know you were a
[Music]
[Applause]
I was just wondering if you wanted to um
you know go out sometime you want to get
a coffee now yes now
I'll just hang on
[Music]
I mean I know this sounds crazy but I
think she might be the one
who goes along with you she really is
great you'll see
any word
she goes to them I bet she hasn't even
seen your text she does travel a lot for
work go to her I'm going to London
. see you get it it's a grand romantic
gesture that is amazing mate 5 000 miles
to surprise a girl you've only met once
especially if she's the one who ghosted
yeah
no no she didn't ghost me she just
doesn't have an international calling
plan oh right
[Music]
where am I oh God do you have the wrong
guy I'm a former wait wait
can you walk goals
thank you
George attacks man oh my God oh my God
you got me kidnapped and tortured all
after one day
I saw the rock
you're the one who blew to London
he was a romantic gesture
get every Bounty Hunter on the continent
I want her black
bigger than you and me
it never occur to you that he could be a
foreign asset trying to compromise your
mission
who the hell are you
I'm the boyfriend
[Music]
do you trust me is that a joke
foreign
[Music]